armored here is playing around with very
high voltages and if anything goes wrong
those sparks can go through him to
ground and he could get a big electric
shock he has created a mini lightning
board inside his garage it looks like
some kind of sci-fi special effect so
what exactly is that stuff this blue arc
is plasma plasma is actually very common
our stars our Sun are all made out of
plasma so how is Amir harvesting the
power of stars in his garage Amir has
created a setup where he's got a wire
attached to a wooden pole connected to
the transformer and the only way he can
complete this as a circuit is if
electricity leaps through the air to the
wire on the pole the air ends up getting
so much energy from this electrical
current that it turns from a gas to
plasma
if you could look at the air molecules
between the pole and the transformer
then what you would see is as the
current flows through these atoms and
molecules are effectively ripped apart
their electrons are stripped off so that
you end up with just the nucleus of the
atom and the electrons flying around
mixing up in a big soup and this creates
that blue arcing flame that we see
between two connections and remember
folks electricity can be deadly so
please don't play with plasma